[Music]
let's start out on that dry cough let's
open the show with a dry cough I'm like
Baba Booey man with the fucking throat
clearing all the time it's the worst
it's like the pandemic is not the time
to be clearing your throat I know it
meant that Luck's told me like my girl
likes told me about a meme she saw it
said I used to cough to cover up my
farts to cover up we fuck anything I can
do I yell cunt anything to cover up the
fact that I'm coughing if you got how
people look at you like you just yelled
the n-word what I just perpetrated was a
different style of covers more than the
Annoying throat-clearing business but
you smoked you used to smoke I did it's
just my play I think what destroyed me
more than anything was huffing nitrous
oxide that'll do it
I did that your your mmm throat I
honestly I don't know like what all is
actually the reason for why my voice is
such a disaster hi you're the Janis
Joplin of the comedy well I'll take it
I'll take an I definitely in my my
journey of recovery you know as we go we
take an inventory of the different
things that really bother us look in the
camera whenever you talk about recovery
okay can your camera carry of recovery
we're supposed to address things in a
certain way by in case like we make we
make inventory of resentments of fears
of you know like harm done other things
you need to apologize right man and on
my fear inventory like it was a big
thing like to two things was like I'm
afraid of like the you know the reality
of my deteriorating apparent and and my
my shitty deteriorating voice and I just
said go ahead and say my sponsor he said
well you know he said I think every said
your voice you kidding me it's kind of
trademark you know he said it's kind of
trademark and as far as your appearance
goes I hate to break it to you but you
were never really like popular because
he were good-looking he's like it wasn't
quite that that got you where you are it
was more you're just like reckless
willingness to shove shit up your ass
like let's be clear about who you are
and what you're about and that helped a
lot like a wait a second here's my we'll
say not to disagree with your sponsor
who clearly knows what the fuck he's
talking about I think my friends and I
always thought you were hot oh well
thank you yeah I think that was always
sort of a part of your appeal if I may
Bogg thank you disregard for your body
and health made you even hotter to us
girls that had been shot why I
appreciate that a lot and we have so
much to get into I know I don't want
where to start but I also I do need to I
start every episode the podcast asking
the guests with no weighing and from me
are we friends I would say so yeah I
would say I would say we are absolutely
friends and I remember the first time we
met it was outside the Hollywood improv
then this wasn't that long ago wasn't
that long ago oh it started no the first
time we met you were with we was at the
George Lopez show and we had a mutual
friend in an old rep of yours I blacked
that out right we met at the George
Lopez shows which they kept just like
prohibitively cold it was so
uncomfortable to be in that fucking
studio everybody tries to emulate what
David Letterman did what David
Letterman's whole psychology was
audiences are gonna stay awake if you
keep the studio at 60 degrees so
everybody always put their studio at 60
degrees because they wanted to be like
Letterman and it's just like a nightmare
for everyone it was the worst it was the
words I've never experienced this too
that cold but an egg they wanted nipples
to be out do your stand-up set also
please don't Google my set on that
because I I say midget like 40 times and
I'll get canceled I have discussion with
women on my podcast about the M word
yeah and and whether or not it was like
you know with the progression of
political correctness if like retro
actively it was a problem to have thrown
that word around some way you're
supposed to call them toddlers now I'm
actually more offended by the the
politically correct term little people
because it's so fucking inherently
belittling to say there's nothing
fucking little is so like little you say
you're little you're small yeah you're
right I think that's more offensive to
me but in any case what was floating
around for coral years or dwarf was I
think dwarf is actually it's a magical
though right but but technically it's
called dwarfism and in a scientific
sense so I think the dwarf would would
be the ticket okay in any in any case we
met at the George Lopez show and that
wasn't really much of an encounter to
speak of but I was probably unconscious
and scared and trying to get your
approval so I probably don't remember
anything those I was in recovery so I
think that it was your this this rep who
since you know there's been distance
between you guys and I think it was more
of an encounter between me and him and
you just happened to be with him copy
that copy that right but it but in any
case we met I was coming out of a Vegas
we were both coming out of the Hollywood
in progress
I had my bicycle and we just started
chatting on this on the sidewalk and for
me like - I was felt a little bit weird
about doing stand-up in LA you know I
like for some reason like alright
because I because I came from another
arena of entertainment I almost feel
like I'm I gonna be like accepted like
there's just this like
sort of social awkwardness that I have
in the stand-up scene in LA and I've
been on tour food so for so long I feel
like man I'm like always that I hardly
like I'm hurting for stage time to go
try on stuff so I don't know like now
I've got more of a model and like when
I'm putting together a new hour like I'd
totally do it you know at the local
spots and that wasn't what I was doing
at the time but I just couldn't believe
because you were so nice to me it was
just like wow like you were just like
curated I just felt like man like
Whitney Cummings like whoa you know I'm
like like impressed and like we just
started sort of just chatted it was the
same thing with me and I think for I am
also at a point and like I follow you on
social whatever and I always know don't
take this the wrong way and I'll try to
not take it the wrong way when you meet
another comic and you see each other and
you're instantly like family and there's
no like sexual weirdness there's no like
we're gonna date or flirt it's like you
know we're just like homies we're just
equals it's the best feeling in the
world to make a best friend like right
away you know I mean well right on I was
just like let's take out next week in
Toronto and we you know that way yeah
then when you posted that you were gonna
be doing a show in Vancouver for just
for laughs and I was like doing a show
in the same fucking theater like the
next night and I was like yo I'm gonna
be there and we ended up and then I kind
of was like I wait to reserve to see how
friendly I'm gonna be able to be with
someone until I meet their partner and
oh yeah god what if his girls whack like
whatever dude she is so awesome she did
it's like I don't know how you scored
this I don't know what I mean no offense
it's it's it's an absolute fact that if
your girl is a girl's girl
you know women know right away anybody
who has met my girl who who really cares
about me who has a close relationship
with me universally they all the
consensus is that I am a better version
of myself because I am with her it's so
cool like it's and and and everybody
passionately loves my girl because we
all have friends
who they're in a relationship with just
yes someone where you're like oh doesn't
challenge them someone that's not their
equal we've all been there we've all
been in a place where we weren't cooked
enough to be with an equal or someone
that had self-respect right you know
how long have you been together and
we're you together before you proposed
we just passed three years we met on
January 7th 2017 our first kiss was
February 5th of 2017 we dated
responsibly for a month
really yeah I've like a history with
that no kissing but did you have sex
before that way the same day we kissed
for the first time we also kissed each
other's peepees makes me think of your
dick is like a baby
like a tiny bag so did you know right
away like this is someone that I'm not
going to be sloppy with this is someone
that I want to pay yeah because I mean
like I just I could say comfortably that
you know from certainly like the age of
11 when I got my first Motley Crue album
I aspired to be a sex addict yeah I
wanted like I loved my liquor because of
just sex drugs and rock and roll and
that was what I wanted to be a fucking
rock star and I didn't care whatever the
shortest distance was between me and
partying like Motley Crue if it involves
shoving things up my ass I didn't
fucking care because that's what I want
to live right I want to be the center of
attention and I want to just live the
life of fucking of debauchery
I want to wet my peepee yeah and and I
mean that was that was how it went down
really I mean that was what I aspired
for you know to be and sex drugs and
rock and roll like all basically turned
on me but this section it's a more
insidious thing because here I was on
tour doing a and then to this day I've
done you know been doing stand-up on
tour for for just about ten years yeah
man
and and still religiously after every
single show you know before I walk off
stage I'd tell the audience that I will
not go anywhere I will not do anything
until I take a photo with every single
audience member who wants one awesome
and I have it set up so that I take the
photos myself with that with that like a
point-and-shoot camera that's real fast
and I pop my bump bump bump up and then
I upload them to my site because also no
offence you guys we love you but you
don't know how to use your camera phone
right you and then you don't get a good
photo the picture it looks like dog shit
it looks like dog shit you're out of
focus like you get Norway tans they wait
until they get out they wait until they
get to you in the Y and then and then
they turn to some rods and say oh can
you take this and that person doesn't
know how to fucking work there and then
it's like we're taking a video and we're
crawling your mom and we're FaceTime
people and also get dope photos for
everybody we want you to get home and
your photo to actually be good yeah
right sure yeah and and I upload I'd
like with within 10 to 15 minutes of me
taking the last photo they are already
available to you at my website myself
but this whole process which I still do
and I still believe in it I think it's
so self-serving it's like grassroots
promotion you send everybody home with
the picture I wonder how this is gonna
affect me in gree it's this pandemics
that you write I mean I think that the
Mean Green is the least of the concern
the concern is everybody packed into the
actual theater club I think we're going
to be doing every other row for a while
I think we might have some class profile
in here and you're in the row business
but the fucking worst thing is that it
was it was it was like the fucking a
week before this pandemic shut
everything down that my agent called up
to say basically congratulations no more
comedy clubs really have graduated any
more comedy clubs and then the fucking
this happens but are the greatest thing
in the fucking world clubs are how you
get so good clubs are how you get out
there and you're really able to feel
people's response and you're really able
to connect like I miss clubs you know
doing theatres is like kind of an ego
thing and you want to show everyone you
can sell out the
but you get in there and you're like god
I can't even see those people back there
right except for the fucking cry I used
to do the first you know the first like
seven or eight years I would do the
Thursday through Sunday yeah that's how
you get better that's Jim and then and
that's why people by the way if you had
gone straight to theatres comics really
wouldn't have liked you
smarmy right but there but dinner you
know when I gotten with Lux and the
whole point wasn't talking about the
meet-and-greets was that for the first
what like four or five years that mean
great after the show as much as it was a
function of you know grass roots
promotion like creating a connection
with the fans it did that every one of
those meet and greets was a glorified
audition to see who the lucky lady was
that would get to suck my wiener that
night you have how do you even have that
conversation by is pre-pandemic when you
could just suck anyone's dick you money
without a 14 day quarantine remember you
gotta put a little hole in your mask and
go down on that I mean how would it go
down I mean it would just be like that's
a hat like happy happy time Rick would
just give you her number or like or like
whatever he would just be like oh hey
you know like yeah you know just tweet
me or like hey yeah dude you should
write down your number like me however
yeah it was it didn't it was never like
smooth but you're not looking for so
romantic you would never remain you know
and and I'm not like I'm not proud to
even like that characterize myself as
that way it's just a reality of how it
was you know but as I see were like when
way it would have been I remembered a
couple things happen I was in Atlanta
during the punchline in krysta petaa he
was like dude my whole act was about it
was about James just
and like that I started out in comedy
with all just like oh I'm steve-o the
jackass guy and I'm gonna tell you every
like y'all graphic and gratuitous yeah
groupie sex story and it's gonna be
really funny because you've already sort
of transcended this bar of extreme like
I you know I think about you you know
when I see you do stand-up I'm like God
his fans have seen him do so much that
he do you feel this pressure to have to
deliver some that so shocking something
so my pressure I think I put on myself
more than anything but yeah I would have
liked a bit where it's like yeah you
know like I couldn't believe it I was
like in a situation with three different
chicks you know and like it becomes
evident that they're all gonna like you
know take turns like going down on me
and I'm terrified because I'm gonna like
and that the first one starts and like
she's doing like way too good of a job
so I shove her off and I good next one
and thank God that one was just started
chewing on my dick like if the two
theists blowjob of all time and I'm like
ah thank God I needed that because now
I'm gonna last a little longer so then I
was like this chicks fucking sucking my
dick like a crocodile and and I've never
been more grateful because I have never
sucked a dick with my friends before
what are they just Grothe is and I feel
like I'm already getting like that sense
of disease that might wear my fiance is
gonna be like why the fuck are you
telling these stories you know
so let me like just sort of make it like
for a reason that I'm describing it is
that is that the Christian pet it was
like yo dude this act of yours it's it's
it's not fucking cool you know he's like
yeah maybe you're getting away with it
now but like at what age do you think oh
and it's jig soaking my dick you know
it's just gonna start like you're gonna
get to an age like you're kind of
already an agency's not it's not funny
it's just creepy and uncomfortable and
like dude you're better than that like
he can do better material smarter than
that yeah there and he was right and all
and I was I was like at the time like
what I'm 45 now at the time I was maybe
38 you know and I I felt like fuck I'm
approaching 40 and like I'm just acting
out sexually you know like I'm acting
out sexually and like then like it's
just not a fucking good look it's not
like the way to be happy in the long run
and so like and in and I made myself a
promise I was like okay I want it in
order to be happy I subscribe to the
idea that I need to learn how to be in a
healthy relationship so step one working
towards that is no more hooking up with
random chicks on the road no more no
more acting out and it was just like
fuck I couldn't keep my promise hey this
all became in real time it became part
of my act I'm like I made myself this
promise and then like the next stop on
tour there I was minding my own business
titty bar dancer comes running over all
excited and she shoves her butt in my
face and then that right there she's got
my autograph tattooed on her butt cheek
it's almost your responsibility right
right it would be rude it would be wrong
it'd be a verbally and emotionally you
can do right and so it like that and
this was my experience was like okay sis
and then I got into therapy you know
when I got into therapy with the you
know the therapy that was like more like
about that
you know anybody was just like a kid and
I ended up like just full-blown like the
approach of you know of recovery yeah
you know it's like you know the full-on
12-step approach to sex addiction and I
just don't even do it like I drove into
it with drugs and alcohol I'm a snob
about furniture I don't like most
furniture you know me I really only like
buying vintage tchotchkes from flea
markets
but I with this brand they I'm just
gonna read this little part cuz I I'm
gonna say it's like very modern and
fresh this is my description of article
furniture modern fresh like a little
smidgen of rustic character and charm
and would you say undertones of
mid-century modern classic which is it's
a lot of yeah sure I think that it's a
classic timeless that's what I look at
the article furniture stuff and I'm like
oh this is still gonna hold up in ten
years like it's not so trendy that I
feel like it's not gonna I'm not gonna
be like what was I think what I bought
that ten years ago you know I'm saying
it's yes it's like it's like oh that's a
good way to put it
no it's table where do you get all this
money to buy all this article so let's
see how they describe it article
combines a curation a boutique furniture
store with the comfort and simplicity of
shopping online articles team of
designers focuses on beautifully crafted
pieces quality materials and durable
construction they're also look I got it
dedicated to modern aesthetic of
mid-century Scandinavian industrial and
bohemian designs that's basically what I
hi described it fair prices you save up
to 30% over traditional retail I know
that's the other thing is that you go on
it and you look at how much it cost and
you're like this this feels like I know
it's like I feel like I'm not getting
scammed on this article is able to keep
their prices low ah because they cut out
the middleman they sell directly to you
they don't do showrooms they don't do
salespeople they don't read they they
don't mark up their retail prices okay
that's why I'm not you love because you
hate nothing more than going to buy
furniture and they're like we have to
order it for you I can't I can't
and then I'm like I'm sure I just want
to buy a chair oh I have to pay for nine
people's salaries like I just want I
just want this chair fast affordable
shipping is available across the USA
Canada is free on orders over 900 900 so
are shaping's gonna be free over nine
hundred ninety nine dollars all in stock
items are delivered in two weeks or less
first purchase of $100 or more
Uncle Tom / Whitney and the discount
will be automatically applied at
checkout that's article need to get $50
off of your purchase of $100 or more
article dot-com / Whitney now here's
what I don't want you guys to do I don't
need you to listen to my podcast and go
oh my god I trust Whitney's taste so
much Whitney's right about everything
Whitney would never lie to me and then
you go to article comm and you're a buy
a bunch of stuff and you don't put my
name in don't do that you need to
support the show let them know we sent
you okay I want them to know who gets
credit around here okay I want them to
know who's boss around tear tag us and
also you know what this my new favorite
thing when you get your furniture tag me
or when you buy it tag me in it and I'll
repost you in my story so that I can
brag that I'm a very influential
influencer okay love you bye okay - do
you need an attitude adjustment before
we start this next ad okay so I'm not
even again I like to try I like to do a
thing where I prove to the listeners
that all the products that sponsor us
that we partner with our products I
actually use I'm not a sellout I'm not
corny I don't just like willy-nilly
peddle my wares and like slap around
brands and products that I don't affect
eclis use so you know how my skin's been
like amazing lately don't you think I
think it's because of the ritual
vitamins that I start I start taking
these I start taking these before the
podcast started by the way I've been
taking fish oil okay and this is the
only fish oil that I will take because
it's the only one that doesn't make me
feel like I'm burping up clam chowder
for the entire day you know what I mean
this is it has this is the only thing I
take I don't take anything else I don't
even put the vitamins in this blender
with my smoothie anymore because I just
I can't so this one I love because it's
you just take two capsules
i nutrients you need to support a strong
foundation for and have it my nails have
been growing faster and not breaking and
my hair is going faster I cut my hair
like I don't know like a month ago and
it's already growing like three inches
so from d3 to omega-3 rituals essential
for women helps fill gaps in a woman's
diet there's no no Naja capsule yeah
that's the other thing you know how
normally when you take a fish oil a pill
you're like you start like gagging and
you're like ah I think I'm gonna puke up
Worf here in a minute
no Naja capsule with ritual vitamins
design is gentle on an empty stomach and
there that's what it there's a mint tab
in every bottle to keep things fresh you
know and now that we're all wearing
masks and we have to inhale our own
breath every day all day this is the
only kind of fish oil you want to take
because it makes that breath minty fresh
no fishy aftertaste common with most
omega-3s now do you want to do the rest
it's also delivered subscription is easy
to start and it's easy to wait it's
important to okay so this is the key no
one wants to go to grocery stores right
now no one wants to go to right like the
the pharmacy this comes to your door
delivered to you Rhona free continue it
is it's only a dollar a day to have the
essential nutrients your body needs
delivered every month with no strings
attached doesn't happen overnight and
right now rich was offering Whitney's
listeners ten percent off during your
first three month fill in the gaps in
your diet with essentials for women a
small staff that helps supports a
healthy foundation for your body visit
ritual a.com slash Whitney to start your
ritual today that's ten percent off
during your first three months or ritual
calm / wait I'm telling you everybody
always asks me what I do to my skin I
truly think it's this good skin starts
inside out should I I mean is that your
new slogan
and like the reason not that my girl
isn't thrilled for me to even be sharing
any of this decide tomorrow to cut it
out it's absolutely not but the reason
why I'd like it's okay is that the world
is full of fucking scumbags
who would never consider themselves let
alone call themselves sex addicts yeah
who are rampantly cheating fucking just
being just shitheads you know I like the
fucking and everything wrong with the
world and like I would rather be someone
who says hey I'm a sex addict yeah
however like I've done like an
incredible amount of work over years to
establish integrity mm-hmm and honesty
and behave in a way that you know so
it's like it's it's right it's like a
blessing and a curse it's a go you know
like I'm with this guy who identifies as
a sex addict but he does all this work
to make sure that to me a sex addict in
recovery is the fucking best catch you
can get because I mean it's sad because
you know I talk about sex addiction as
often as I can identify as a love addict
and al-anon and all that everyone knows
that about me but uh you know sex
addiction is one of the fucking most
insidious ones because of like food
addiction in right unlike drugs now just
know eliminating it there's no
eliminators you just have to learn how
to moderate imagine having to do cocaine
once a day times a week you know I so it
to me those are the fucking bad-ass the
people that are in sex addiction
recovery it's it's a graduate school
that's what we call we call it graduate
school because they die most insidious
and you know and you know four people
are always wondering am i sex addict and
but this with porn every time I talk
about this everyone's like I must I do
that it it really is when it makes your
life unmanageable so if you're having
sex three times a day with your girl
like that's awesome if you're late for
work if you're not paying your rent if
you're not you know sure and when it
stops being fun when it starts feeling
like an obligation and not something
you're deaf
porn is a no-fly zone for me I can't
fuck with it but and in sex addict
recovery like each person defines their
own sexual astray
that's right because some addicts can
participate in activities that others
can't and so we kind of create our own
our own model and my sex addiction
manifested in what I learned when I got
in there was sexual anorexia which is
where you deprive the person you're with
of sex to try to control them which is a
whole other weird fucked up I understand
sexual anorexic as I ended up with the
therapist was like yo you know cuz I
would keep coming to the therapist I'd
be like fucking did it again fuck yeah
yeah he was like I got to recommend an
intensive outpatient you know and so I
did that in 2013 and did you do know cuz
I did know celibacy yep I did know sex
for a year you recommend they recommend
not only no sex but they recommend like
full-on celibacy no masturbation no like
just straight up and they recommend like
in 30 days 60 days 90 days I did 431 day
that's because like I've had to quit
like coffee and stuff like how many how
many days was it hard and then did it
start to just become you know and like I
did not blow a load for the entire year
of 2014
yeah it was October 2013 - I believe
February of 2015
like is that it not blows is that
physically painful for a while I did I
remember I'd joke so as it went through
this hole as I went through this whole
like saga it just became material yeah
and it actually like kind of justified
those earlier bits because it's like I
started out here and that first hour was
a journey of like yeah you know I got
into it and I genuinely approached this
this sexual addiction recovery saying
just out loud like you know like my
whole motto was I am preemptively doing
the work to become the man the love of
my life deserves that's gonna make me
cry so that
so that I didn't because if I were to
meet the love of my life I wouldn't and
she wouldn't know she would have known I
knew first so I had to become I'd to
become that in order to be ready to meet
Lex so and I do all this work to you
know and so and I love that because I
hear so many people they're like I just
want like a good man and I just want a
good one that's like but you're not a
good why what do they see in you why
don't you elevate yourself to where I or
equal B be the kind of the person that
you want is not gonna be interested in
you you're gonna be just a fucking bunch
of a when we attract people who are as
healthy as we are but uh it's like it's
like the level of water like like needs
like attracts like
and then I love here and the reason it's
so important to talk about sex addiction
is so much of it is about shame and
right aftermath and the shame aftermath
you know I was talking about this with
Dax the other day is like I used to
cheat in relationships and like the
cheating wasn't enjoy it was just about
that adrenaline dopamine shame hit
afterwards I'm so gross why would I do
that was so good like I said and then
the next thing was the acting out with
food yeah it's so not so that's my mind
and I arrived at the conclusion with
food that obviously but really what I'm
after because because I've got this
little negotiation system in my head
where it's like fuck I said it used to
be a cigarette after it after a meal
yeah and then it turned into like I just
a pie I become a fucking World War I fan
as soon as I finished my meal now I
become a werewolf yeah sugar crazy
yeah and I started thinking to myself oh
I gotta want to dessert but but not but
but I'll be so mad at me you know and
it's like no I want it but I shouldn't
have it and then I and then I give in
and and and I fucking just beat myself
up and I realize that there's obviously
something very rewarding about the shame
really like that's like the hit that I'm
after right yeah I think more than the
more than I want to eat the dessert is
that I somehow I'd take some perverse
pleasure or satisfaction in having
something to fucking feel awful about
yeah that's right it's sort of like back
to the oh yeah I'm a piece of shit
self-esteem was getting a little too
high there for a minute dude my shit
used to be so gnarly like mine was very
much it was like binging but I never
purged because I think that my need to
isolate and hide in fear of like deep
friendships I would eat just binge I'd
have like five acts of cereal and then
go to crunch on sunset I'd go to a gym
and workout for like four hours and it
was my way of like debilitating myself
so that I didn't have to have
relationships or friendships or whatever
you know foods a lot about like hiding
and control it was crazy and it got to a
point where there was food and again
food you have to eat three times a day
right gnarly right and yeah my bottom
with food was this whole negotiation
like oh I'm gonna die I'm not gonna get
anything in the candy but the fucking by
the cash register hmm not even me I look
over here and there's a big bag of
fucking fun-sized butter fingers and it
says it says like 65 calories per bar
I'm like oh if it's only 65 calories now
mind you I don't even subscribe to Dairy
you know like I think dairies fucking
awful I don't know that any memory you
know but I'm so powerless over the sugar
McColl's shit
and then I buy the whole fucking bag and
I ate the whole fucking bag a whole bag
of fun sighs butterfingers and now that
wasn't even like as bad I don't think is
when I went to see The Joker movie with
Joaquin Phoenix I got a whole tub of
caramel popcorn which I ate in concert
with a jumbo pack of Red Vines I said I
filled my mouth with a handful of
fucking caramel popcorn mouth full and
then I started chomping on a bunch of
fucking red vines chewing it all up
together and I ate all of it and I'm
like okay that's my bottom that's my
bottom right so I finally reached out to
somebody in the food program and I've
got a sobriety date with sugar from
October 13th fucking awesome yeah so I'm
like a dive like I'm if you can't drugs
and alcohol a separate I'm solidly
planted in for 12-step fellowships mein
addiction is 12-step programs at this
I'm barreling towards my fifth barreling
towards because because I did with the
spending and they're gonna come over to
Alan I'm one of these I shake your and
you're gonna just be like oh what the
fuck was all that mess cuz that like
Alan on like because it gets to like the
root of all this shit you know cuz I was
going to all these programs all these
programs obviously we have different
experiences and but they say that Alan
on covers 0-2 when you started using and
then the other program start when huh
start using whatever it is to
anesthetize you know yeah so like all
that inner child work and stuff cuz my
eating stuff was so gnarly nothing could
I couldn't do anything about it it was
just because it was all about control
and the more people tried to help me the
more I push them away and you know it's
about control so when people try to
control you you've recoiled deeper into
your disease and you know someone
telling you you're too thin you start
getting paranoid going like they're just
jealous and I have to get thinner and
I'm not that wild you know and the
eating stuff is so performative to like
you're at dinner with someone and you're
like oh you know I think I'm gonna get
the burger I'm gonna get the burger and
then the waiter comes and you're like
I'm just gonna salad no dressing just
the oil on the side like you end up just
having to perform and pretend like you
eat like it's just like exhaust and it's
exhausting for everyone but I did these
like inner child exercises where you
have to write letters to your inner
child and you know II as if you were
feeding a five-year-old and it really
just like changed my whole view on food
Wow and that's like that the inner child
shit is for the Fellowship's
that that are related to behavior that
you can't just cut out that's right yes
right as it come becomes about like
nourishing not shaming you know there's
no like you can't eat that you should
use because we talk to ourselves the way
our parents probably talk to us right or
the way our inner monologue used to talk
to us when we didn't get what we need
from our past
it would be criminal
to talk to a child the way I talked to
myself that's what we say we that's how
we're able to get out of it cuz we just
felt like you would never talk to a
child like this right if you said any of
this out loud to a child you would Child
Services would come and take you to jail
why would you ever talk to
self like by now I get it because we're
all just giant five-year-old straight no
I get it but I'm sorry like I know I by
no means what I ever and I had before on
other podcast ones but but what I ever
see no don't know I said told the story
on Marc Maron's what the fuck podcast
that that I thought that I'd asked him
to cut out after the fact and and he did
yeah it's a big deal but but I've been
I'm not saying to edit it out but I am
just very sensitive to my partner ya
know for all the stuff and I think that
it didn't make sense because to me it
makes sense they hey that's where I was
and and and I'm so grateful for the
relationship I have with her and I love
what you're saying because you know I'm
in this place where you know we talk
about something in program called
restraint of pen and tongue where not
everybody needs to know everything and I
write sometimes we think like but I'm
rigorously honest and I've done it right
you know here my character defects like
that does not mean you need to tell your
partner everything you've ever done
that's it's that's not a lie that's
right it's honest like we are allowed to
omit if it's going to if it's gonna kind
exception when to do so and her mother
that's right so yeah you know so it's
also it's like don't just puke up the
things you've done in your past just go
but I'll be honest tonight
that's not sure see it's nice less about
what I share with Lux yeah cuz we're cuz
we're super open it's more when I share
in a public level that's our and
certainly the whole world doesn't need
to know everything right but in this
case I feel it's appropriate you know as
I again like I said I would rather be
somebody who identifies as having issues
and addressing that yes you know that
they're not but there's something else
that mmm-hmm
I was so uncomfortable about this and I
didn't speak up about that either but
but when you were promoting your special
yeah just by the way is in the most
fucking incredible hour I love you oh
god it's the most renewed some most
incredible hour I'm so psyched that you
had to see it live ahead of time you
gave me so much confidence I ran my hour
in front of you in Vancouver Vancouver I
was gonna say Toronto and
I was starting to wonder if it was you
know you and your at that phase where
you got it and then you're running it
and then you kind of feel like a phony
cuz you're sort of like right not
wrapped in the scripts adding anything
new and you're sort of like start to
beat yourself up and you said to me
afterwards I remember it like it was
yesterday you went you're sitting on a
monster
oh yeah 100% and I was concerned about
going to see your hour because that time
at the Hollywood improv when we first
chatted on the sidewalk yeah like I saw
your set that night and you were just
working it out the me to Moe wasn't
working the me to movement was brand new
yeah you're you were like coming in
really hot you know like like what do I
forget what it was really something
along like what do I gotta do to get you
know I know what the joke is I had a
fucking gotta get dude it was there was
something really aggressive would either
bomb or kill ya and it was about Aziz
and it was it was something like I heard
that this there is a celebrity who took
this girl back to his house and they had
a bunch of wine and they had bad sex and
I was like who is this Prince Charming
something that there is that how
generationally a woman who's 36 sees
nothing wrong with that thing it's
nightly I think that that I do
remembered specifically but that sounds
right and I remember if I'm if if I've
got it wrong the feeling it conjured up
was like as if you were saying god I
just think sexual harassment is so
flattering
something like that but I'm joking right
that I bet another forty minutes about
how you shouldn't do that are you sure
yes sure I'm not suggesting that in any
way that I was wrong or anything but I
just remember feeling ooh you know like
she came in really hot and then by the
time by the time you were in Vancouver I
was just like wow like she just fucking
took what she was working on and just
crap
that molded it into this chest
masterpiece I really believe it's just
so fucking impressive that it's the
biggest compliment you can hear from a
comedian you respect seeing something
from it's like you know embryonic stages
at chipping away at the marsh or you
know at the service dog analogy fuckin
fantastic but but but when you're
promoting that special and he had the
robot right like he came he came over to
my house to film me interacting with the
RO that's right right and thank you by
the way and here like that there was no
like particular plan there was I didn't
know I have any idea like what it was
but like I really wanted to be funny
like I just so I wanted you know I felt
like you know a little bit intimidated
you know like by the situation like you
know like Whitney's over and like no
we're filming and like she's treating me
as like as as a comic like sort of
respecting me as like someone who she
considers to be funny and I was just in
in try hard mode and like here I'm just
like okay with the robot and I come out
and like and I'm like I say to the robot
like so what's gonna what's it gonna
take for you and me to fuck or something
like that and I'm just like in my head
I'm like why did I say that like why the
how the fuck did that just come out of
my mouth and I remember I just remember
being like that was so disrespectful to
my girl that was so fucking it was just
such a cheap approach and it was just so
like just like overtly creepy and like I
just was spinning in my head like oh my
god the fucking and I forget if I
brought it up to Lux before or after it
appeared on like the Instagram what did
she say and I cut it out no no no no she
was like I don't watch this video
like she has her own life like I forget
if it was before or after it showed up
on Instagram but I brought it up with
her and I was light and I just said I
just said babe like I'm so not proud of
of this moment I just want you to know
that I was just like in a motor but I
just wanted to fucking try so hard to be
funny and like whatever just like my god
you know like be shot I can get the
laugh you know and like I'm just not in
and she and she said just like hey thank
you for thank you for saying that to me
you know thank you for like
demonstrating with your sensitive to my
feelings and you know and it just like
it came and went without without it you
know which to me is like the crux of you
know an amazing relationship I was gonna
say perfect but we don't use that where
I is not the absence of conflict not the
absence of doing that it's just how you
can address them and how quickly you can
recover like it's just amazing like the
miracle of just saying hey I'm sorry
about that it took me so long to number
one even know when I was being
disrespectful acrossing the line right
so I'm being funny and like this is who
I am and I'm brash and like I make sex
jokes and legs not I out you like but
what I'm hearing from you which is just
like so important and I think anyone
listening in relationships that are sort
of confused it took me 15 years to
understand this the amount of respect in
your relationship it took me so long to
realize that I've been in love with
people I didn't respect I've been
obsessed with people that didn't respect
me like respect is like the number one
thing and it took me so long to
understand that sure and I think that
like consideration is you know part part
of it but you also can see yourself like
you have done the work like and this is
why you deserve this incredible
relationship because you're not waiting
for her to go hey that my friend saw
that and that was weird and you're like
what do you mean I'm a fucking comedian
like Noida who guys calm down
relax I didn't wanna I think I did wait
until it came out because like it was
like words never and I can get used to
cried like it just would fall into the
category of like dude you know she'd
need to know that and I don't know why I
probably should have been like I should
cut this no no no you know it was fine
and
and I was checking out like I was
checking out your podcast you know I was
like I wonder what what what Whitney's
YouTube presence is yeah cuz I've been
like I was like YouTube's almost made
for me it's like incredible how hard you
kill on there because it's it's you know
everyone's like but YouTube's mostly
guys so I'm kind of trying to figure
that out I mean it's it's a I was I was
curious because because I don't do my
bike to start we both are new on the
bandwagon
perfect timing got him ready for
pandemic rush I just saw something
recently that said there are 700,000
podcast that are around the world there
is something that that is that is a
ballpark estimate of how many podcasts
there are every fucking asshole has a
podcast this is a true story I get I
mean this is how you know a friend of
mine was like oh my trainer would like
to interview you for air pocket right
the guy that this rescue organization
like everyone's capture and it ranks
among the most annoying questions that
you can ask is will you do my podcast
how's your podcast is relatively new
you've done what five six ivory I've
recorded six and put out five so let me
tell you something about the people
you're asking to take away your guilt
let me remove your compunction they're
all fuckin narcissists who just want to
be on camera and talk about themselves
for two hours you're fine it's a I
thought the hardest thing in the world
was gonna be getting people on my
podcast
as soon as you get a couple people
everyone's ego skip bruised like what am
I gonna do you're what right like the
everyone doesn't want to be the person
that wasn't asked so don't start coming
out of the woodwork don't worry I mean
it's it's it's anxiety induce now that
you've had Ronda Rousey and Demi Lovato
and all these celebrities they're gonna
want to be on it so that they're in the
same as lon
I I think that that is
it's gonna snowball yeah I'm hoping it
will because at current I just feel and
you're always so good I remember when
you did rogue in you did an episode
where you talked it just totally blew my
mind
about drug use and about how it I might
be getting this wrong like corrodes the
wall yeah exactly
I was like this guy needs a fucking
podcast I remember that as a first
psychosis you you said something about
you think that life is designed in like
cartman's yes compartments and that if
you take enough substances you will
erode the barriers in between the
compartments and thus open yourself up
to spiritual entities where you start
hearing voices because I believe to this
day that the hallucinations the voices
were very fucking real 100% I still
subscribe to it there's fucking real
spirits I think that the drugs made you
hallucinate it's that they corroded the
walls that right because they opened me
up to two other dimensional shit because
I got as totally real the problem is
that is it's it's a very crude and like
it's it opens you up to all nature said
entities where you you let in really
low-frequency fucking demon shit because
we're just like on autopilot you're
actually like you did the Innes in a
sense those barriers are like protective
you know like if you want to open
yourself up to more stuff like that like
meditation like like it's like a high
level frequency shit yeah and it's much
more subtle whereas you just open up the
floodgates and the demons come pouring
in and it's like ah like that's
psychosis dude I did ayahuasca like I've
been very again I grew up an alcoholic
home so my drug was control
perfectionism like I'm an al-anon my
drug was rescuing drug addicts and
chasing them around and try to get sober
right I'm pretty fun loved me great
fucking match and I had never done like
really substances much like I did LSD
when I was like younger just sort of
like make people like me that we're
doing that or what
it was just like I was codependent I was
like alright you're doing it I'm doing
it I cannot relinquish control so LSD
was my nightmare like I was just like I
had no fun I didn't enjoy it but I did i
wass got like three years a two and a
half years ago for the first time in
Robin Quivers she's she's ayahuasca
forever amazing I mean yeah I think God
I figured that if she did it or she
wanted to do I think she did it I have
this weird thing with Howard Stern where
because we're friends and I'm friends
with his way I try to not listen to him
because I feel like I'll become a fan
it'll be weird I did like I have a such
a different experience I'm just like
with that and and this will just create
problems but I used to I used to be like
a regular Howard Stern guest you know oh
yeah I use I think I was on there like
16 times you know why and truly one of
the best I mean ranked as like one of
the glass well thinking and and I had
this whole routine of like I would
surprise him with nobody knew where I
was gonna do and it was just like some
fucking maniac shit and and back then I
decided I never listened I was so busy
getting loaded I was just like whatever
look listen to Howard Stern and right
around the time when Howard became a
judge on America's Got Talent
you know like it was really that time
represented an evolution of the Stern
Show and my theory is that Howard he
became much more family-friendly for
having been on a network family-friendly
show as a judge on a GT and he all of a
sudden like I don't say it took away the
edge but like his show evolved around
that time yeah to be really like just so
a list you know like right around that
time and so so this is the ashen lawn of
guest like that and like that
see that I just did the floor my grab
for the guest was above me and I could
no longer be a guest on the Howard Stern
Show but for the most part my career has
been stand up to her yeah and in digital
stuff yeah and I've built like a really
like pretty substantial I'll put a video
up and have like 5 million views in like
two weeks just like Jesus inside I'm
really grateful and I'm hustled but you
also so evolved in a way where you know
I've seen a lot of the stuff that you've
done like it's so hard to stay shocking
and surprising like you or one of the
people that I look at and I see what the
YouTube stars are doing and that sounds
like such an odd thing to say but like
you're doing things that are super
extreme and super surprising without
like electrocuting rats and poking
Corbitt you know I mean it's not like
just mindless artless stunts there's it
always feels like a really well thought
out
smart sketch well thank you and that did
that that bring that's sloppy it's not
just like this artless like I don't
think anybody got got in trouble for
saying anything about this journey I'm
just still such a fan I just I feel like
Sarah Silverman the way I just worship
Him you know I got fucking worship
Howard Stern yeah and he's a legend
which I just don't want to listen
because everyone I know he's like it's
like a cult and I'm like I guess if I
start listening to the show I'm gonna
start I'm gonna put him on a pedestal
and it's gonna make our friendship weird
because I had never when I did the show
I had never heard the show before not
because I wasn't I just a lot of people
grew up listening to in the car with
their dads and I just didn't have that
experience and I literally the day
before when people found I was going on
everyone called me and they were like
this is a great buzz can we I come like
people right like I do so many things in
my life I've met so many amazing people
Howard is the only time people say can I
come with you right I'm like John Cleese
is on my TV show tomorrow do want to
come to that like now we're good right
Howard they just want to seat right and
he's epic and I remember the first time
I went on they were like you're gonna
have to ride something called a sybian I
was like you know now you definitely
don't have to
it was you know like I feel like he'd
love to have a conversation with you
about this how men especially the public
eye who have you know colorful paths of
evolving for the woman that I'm so glad
that I've gotten serious about all that
before it's just so nice to not be
distracted by the chasing around and the
just the fucking nonsense it's like a
time job oh dude it's awful yeah but
yeah I think it's it's just crazy that
we both just described that the read we
try not to listen to Howard you're
situated for surgery diverse just like
III have this superstitious belief that
if I go back to not listening and if I
just really like I don't have fucking
time to be listening and being careful
with the fucking serious app because I'm
putting channeling my time and effort
back into my fucking career to earn
myself into a spot where I'm on that
goddamn self again no I think that it's
it's interesting and it's in the things
he wanted to talk about our changing you
know it the worst is when I go on there
and like like what you said about when
the robot came over the worst is when I
go on there and I'm just like anyway so
I had a threesome and he's like look I
don't want to talk about what you're
right relationships legs like I'm I'm
doing I told me right I think he wants
this really perverted like period
lascivious conversation right no I've
evolved and I'm like oh sorry thing I
did the things I didn't I stapled my
ballsack to my leg I went in there I
fucking set my head on fire I did fuck I
swallowed five goldfish and burnt them
up like Isis stun gun to myself I'm
fuckin like yeah and then I think now
like it's like now I'm good on that now
you would go in and just cry and be
vulnerable right I don't think he wants
to see that you know but in any case I
gotta pee
okay go pee and then I'm gonna to and
then I'm gonna say about you're gonna go
right here in pee okay I like this makes
me think we are so cool
the fact that you can just say I have to
go pee Oh what if I throw an ad we
haven't done that in four months
Stevo
went to go take a shit so now a word
from our sponsors
hey Benton it's Whitney I'm doing ads
and I'm frankly sick of you not pulling
your weight
oh I'm sorry so we're gonna do an ad for
my favorite hair company task yeah the
best so can you please do it so that I
can take a fucking break yeah they're
really good
and you know I've been using them
non-stop because I don't wash my hair I
just use the dry shampoo me too i've
been using as well I just use another
day just doing quarantine while I'm
alone I've been trying to perfect 80s
hair oh yeah are you using the spray or
the dry shampoo wait the five-in-one
leave-in conditioning spray is that what
you're using yeah it leaves your locs
smoother shinier healthier and happier
look at that ideal for those whose hair
just is not cooperating lately which is
mine this collection has an ability to
instantly deliver five benefits in one
lightweight spray specialty Brenda I
mean greet blend why me I'm talking like
you I miss you so much that I started
stuttering what are you doing what sir
did you get a job in a different podcast
what's happening how do you know all
that against the heat and locks in
moisture while styling this way your
color confront will see that's what so I
been coloring my own roots because I am
known to get a gray or two because I
read too much news
and when you use this it doesn't like
screw up all your color so the leave-in
conditioning spray are available in
three different flavors Argan coconut I
do coconut and you do tea tree in that
concept my is your scalp cuts or all our
colors say free of sulfates parabens
vacillates Fatali aids can you pronounce
that all the five-eighths balance no
chemicals no artificial colors gluten
formulated to meet the needs of your
specific hair type also cruelty free
love it's five in one leave-in
conditioning spray and other has
products available amazon.com online
in-store Ulta Walmart Walgreens Target
CVS and we're excited to announce a task
is now hosting weekly giveaways love it
for our listeners where you can win a
hundred dollar prize pack that includes
shampoos conditioners leave-in sprays
dry shampoos and more and if you're
watching this on youtube i'm putting it
in right now this is how I do it right
kind of on the this is how I get my 90's
beach look hold on I'm just doing it
just so you guys can see for your chance
to win hask beauty.com slash whitney and
this one is my favorite color too it's
like a pretty like lilac also guys get
this for your girl i promise you she
will not pick a fight with you for a
while good eye look everyone's asking me
but sorry last thing i'm gonna say about
this hold on I'm gonna call you right
back cuz it sounds like you're in a
submarine everybody asked me how I get
my hair look cute this is it
you just put as much of this in as
possible and it makes it like super
thick and delicious and sexual and
voluminous see that and it does you know
what can I say one more thing about this
it the dry shampoo doesn't leave like
white residue on your hair so it doesn't
look like you like you know fell in a
vat of baby powder it goes on like
really clean see that see how much cuter
my hair is getting look the people
you probably have no idea what's
happening but look but look at me on
Instagram and look how cute my hair
looks like how thick it looks I feel
like I look like um Jennifer Connelly
and twins remember her hair in that
movie it's like super thick look at that
Benton where are my nume undies remember
I told you to order me more which by the
way wasn't even about the ad sponsorship
they sent me some because they're we're
partnering with them and then I was like
I'm never taking these underwear off and
I hate underwear no I swear to God one
time I was so annoyed that I only had
one pair that I almost took them out of
the laundry and warm inside out which I
don't recommend doing but that's how
comfortable me undies are I wanted to
wear the same one twice without washing
didn't tell our audience how many times
I've asked you to order me more and you
haven't okay and three times where are
you gonna get me one so with the little
mom okay I had look I don't even need to
read this I'm telling you okay
so here's the here's what I do need to
tell you me undies will deliver them
there's a membership okay enik so i no
one wants to go to a store right now
nobody wants to have to go in they will
just magically appear at your door it's
like it's like having a pervy santa
claus drop off underwear you know every
membership comes with statewide savings
early access free shipping and zero
reasons to ever leave your house which
is the key just grab just underwear guys
they don't only have underwear they have
great socks why haven't I got this
they have waves where's my pajamas
t-shirts and everything you need to be
cozy in your house they have onesies why
haven't you gotten me those you know
really be the Oregon for myself me
undies has an offer from my listeners
any first-time purchasers you get 15%
off
and free shipping okay 100% satisfaction
guarantee
to get your 15 percent off your first
pair of free shipping and a 100%
satisfaction guarantee you got to go to
me undies dot-com slash Whitney that's
me M e UND i es comm slash Whitney this
is how comfortable me undies are okay
ready so I started kind of hanging out
with this guy this is like random dude
and because it's because I it's been a
while I shaved my what would you call am
I allowed to say my me undies area the
area that my undies would normally touch
so I started shaving that and so I
shaved
oh my bikini line and this is actually
the highest compliment I can give a pair
of underwear I had me unease on
afterwards no razor burn no rash no
rubbing no chafing it's very rare I like
I've never had this experience where I
shave that area put on underwear and it
didn't create like a frickin forest fire
just saying so you can shave against the
grain and put these underwear on and
still not look like you have some kind
of horrible STD I'm not sure I'm not
sure but here's the deal with me in my
ads I really believe in the products
that sponsor us and I say no to some
some of them I say no but I truly love
this product so I'm gonna be authentic
and that's all I can really do and if
you don't if you don't want me undies I
can't help you it just means you hate
your genitals and that's that's between
you and your psychiatrist and your
relationship with your mom and I'd like
to stay out of it
me undies dot-com slash Whitney again if
you don't do slash Whitney I just you're
you're you hate me dude nothing is
better than just having peed on a
podcast and coming back fresh just
coming back fresh dict fresh ready to
there's nothing worse than thinking
about peeing while you're trying to be
funny
there's nothing worse yeah I love these
arms I wanna he's not talking about my
arms he's talking about the microphone
arms I
feel like I want to fight with all of
Rogen's fans in his comments when people
like she sucks I'm like dude I had to
pee so bad
give me a break you read the comments I
don't sometimes Rogen's got like a army
of people most of the people to listen
just like it and move on with their day
most people don't comment right but he's
got like a subreddit group that sort of
picks apart every guest like in good
ways about you know is crazy it's just
it's unbelievable and for all the you
know there we talked about Howard Stern
like it's actually the one thing that
you can do in my career yeah it used to
be like oh I heard John Howard if I was
on Howard I'd hear it for the rest of
the all day yep but you do Rogan that's
it it's even crazier
it's wild know I'll walk by like a group
of construction workers they're like
like can can we just like even the
fucking political influence where he
says I think I might vote for Bryden
yeah Burt Bernie and I think I'm Bernie
and then all of a sudden Bernie was the
front that's right that's right not just
numbers up but in the lead and you do
this like it's you know I think it was
Tennessee Williams who said and I hope
this doesn't come off pejorative but he
said that like there's three cities in
LA New York San Francisco and Los
Angeles and the rest is Cleveland like
most people are not able to connect with
non cosmopolitan human beings and we're
on the road we meet people we do meet
and greets like we know what people
value we know what they laugh at like
we're not coming from this elitist place
of like I'm better than you and he's not
like didactic in lecture II and I think
that people really appreciate that and
he's not pretending he always knows the
answer like he'll say one day I don't
know about this maybe I'll vote for this
person maybe I won't vote for this right
he's not saying like this is who to
fucking vote for you're stupid right
right no no he's very much he's very
palatable in that way and it's he will
say like dude don't listen to me I'm a
dummy he'll describe
Sophos dummy but however that's so not
the case sounds like he's so insightful
and like it's crazy like he just had Tom
green on and Tom Green III felt Tom
green really like confronted him saying
dude look you've got a responsibility
like here you don't understand how much
influence I think that when Tom Green
was specifically motivated by
Hardin Joe Morgan said I would vote for
Trump over Biden yeah and then he will
get around to clarify that hey I would
vote for Whoopi Goldberg over and over
by Denard vote for anybody have goddamn
dementia yes yeah you know but I think
Tom Green was really got really scared
Trump reelected or some shit I don't
know exact I couldn't hang in there for
though the whole thing I was at yeah I
mean yeah that's just scary but also we
can't treat human beings like they're
idiots that don't have their own
opinions in case you don't I mean I
think that like you know there's also
that you know we also have to resign
ourselves to the fact that people are
idiots with their own opinions I don't I
would go both ways and and you know
because I'm the first to say I just
don't know about something I think it's
also like the kind of people that listen
to Roga and like you know like they're
smart they they want to be independent
thinkers and they're you know he's
they're not zombies Rogan I I heard is
the largest media outlet on the planet
yeah like period no but like not by a
thousand not by 5,000 by like like
literally like tens of millions just
funny when someone's like oh my god I'm
number two on the charts behind rogue
and it's like but you're not right
behind right you're about 50 million
down here here's the thing about being
on the charts because when my podcast
came out I was ranked on the trip the
charts are only based on new subscribers
that's right so so when you're a brand
new podcasts like you have a higher
subscriber gain right for that window of
time yeah but that's because you're new
and everybody's only just signing up for
the first time you've got
like this little wave coming in you know
what I love about you you're so like
you're so you're such a good business
mate like you care so much about
understanding what you're doing I thank
you for the kind words and I really uh
yeah I give a shit about everything like
too much take control of your business
you know like you understand what I'm
just sort of like I've no idea I don't
know I'm just ranked I don't know I
don't know I don't I don't
a to that I lately my producers rolling
in I don't know if I believe all of that
but um but yeah I mean it's it's it's
interesting and I toyed with the idea of
doing a podcast for a long long time and
what was your give me - what was your
trepidation about it
it was fucking I want to be on the
bandwagon Jesus am I really gonna do
this
it seemed for a while podcast was like
that's what you did if you couldn't like
a lot of us had it you couldn't make it
any other way
but now it's to me completely the
opposite it's it's interesting and I and
I really didn't want to have to fucking
ask him because I would personally feel
so annoyed when somebody said I was
really like if I have not heard of the
podcast the answer is no but then
invariably I know the person so it's
like a flag is uses my body okay and
then how many times I just fucking so
just pissed because you're driving a van
natta cos at 3:00 right and it's fine
ever open mind but then but then like I
get there and I'm doing it because I'm
the person as a friend yeah and then I
sit down and they take me down the same
fucking beaten path of every fucking why
I'm just like oh yeah Clown College let
me know like that same just they fucking
grab me and take me hostage down the
same goddamn fucking perhaps that I've
been in the food oh I'm recording the
same podcast over and my thing is if you
couldn't have me on listen to my other
ones to see what I've been asked at
least do a little research
like so how did you get in comedy is it
hard to be a woman in comedy like right
it's 50 times right and and so in any
case it's annoying to be asked well I do
your fucking podcast and then send then
over there or now I'm gonna be the
asshole same way you do my podcast and
so I said okay you know why I got to a
point where it's like it's just so fun
I'm just I'm blowing I'm dropping the
ball by not doing that right this is a
deficiency in my digital profile yes
sorry I gotta do this but let me at
least make it convenient that was where
I came up with the idea to get a
campervan where it's like hey the studio
isn't a fan and I can take it to you
wherever and whenever is most convenient
for you but I started out by buying this
this is itsy-bitsy little fucking
campervan I got suction cups with the
mic arm stuck to the window
the idea being way it's gonna be like
I'm gonna drive around my guest gets to
me that's my biggest thing it's not that
I went to your podcast it's just driving
there driving back it's now it's like a
four-hour door-to-door thing oh my god
but the thing was that I was trying to
podcast while driving so I got so I've
got this fucking microphone yeah both me
and my guest
it's there's just the microphone just
right in between our face and an airbag
and we're driving and I'm the worst
driver ever
plus I'm distracted because I'm trying
to podcast while I'm driving that's why
I'm gonna fucking crash into something
the airbag is gonna explode and you're
gonna have this fucking shure sm7b
whatever the fuck it's called like it's
gonna be fucking through your orbital of
fucking I mean did is the word and then
on top of that and inevitably there's
going to be the point where the guest is
it is either just over oh I didn't
realize the time or like yeah like wow
I'm not gonna take kindly to what you've
just said I'm gonna go ahead and call it
call it a care yeah I'm done and it's
gonna feel really fucking kidnappee when
at that point you got to drive them back
to where you you know yeah yeah yeah I
was like this this doing a while driving
thing is not the tick no not the tickets
and then I got into tattooing so I
started decided that I need a bigger
thing anyway
certainly tattooing people oh my god and
and I'm like surprisingly thank God I'm
fascinated by this do I try so fucking
hard did you practice on oranges isn't
that what you practice on yes you can
you can but for me I had the luxury but
during my meet and greets yeah which I
still do like they'd like more than a
few times people I have come through the
line with a tattoo but here we tend to
me amazing I sure man fuck it you know I
don't care I've tattooed a bunch people
who just made it easy to grab the gun
and do it I can already tell that you're
good at it because the way you hold your
fingers like this you do this you do
this ah what did you just do
I was like yeah you're like overhanded I
mean and that's not to say that I got
like good because so many people
presented me with the opportunity to
tattoo them but one time the last time I
had a guy at my meet and greet and you
know I show up with the tattoo guy it's
not a gun it's a tattoo machine and in
the last and then I thought you know now
I'm like in the YouTube game like really
like yeah looking for ideas for I said
what if I made a youtube video where I
didn't go to Center to tattoo like
give-give crazy tattoos but like what
I'll be compelling about it is that I'm
gonna try as fucking hard as I can to do
the best job I possibly can yeah and I
got somebody who goes to you know let
that guy I was like okay but I got two
shows tonight and now it's gonna be
fucking 2:00 in the morning I'm gonna
give you a tattoo that like we can fit
in the and into one snapchat momma's
name on his ass and that was done can I
ask you since you're an expert cuz I'm
gonna fight with someone about this is
the lighter touch tattoos that are
becoming kind of in the zeitgeist like
the super light ones do they fade
faster when you say lighter touch I
don't think that that's got anything to
do with the touch itself as much as with
the thicker lines that's what I should
be saying are thicker are these thin
line tattoos that we're kind of seeing
on Instagram not ask locks that one okay
you can ask her I'm not exactly expert
yet I'm still an apprentice let's ask
her I only like I only want to tattoo
like really if I can I want I really
want to because my deal is like I want
to get a bunch of tattoos my canteen
here's my portfolio that's actually
really fucking good it leads the
procession for good reason that's it and
you spelled it right and everything yeah
but man for that did you have to do
stencil at first and then you draw it on
you can swipe through we'll make it
quick so that we don't a lien ate any of
our lists no the love and viewers yeah I
mean that is fucking amazed that a
circumcised or uncircumcised I'm glad
that's a banana you guys that's also a
dick have you seen the Takashi six nine
portrait yet because it's a pretty proud
job dude that is how did it long to take
you to do that I want to say an hour or
two that's fucking great now the wedding
portrait oh I want all my dogs on my
forearm there you don't idea dukes if
you're gonna get a forearm tattoo get it
like Lux dude this is fucking awesome
thank you did you always know you could
draw I cut me again that's tracing so
but you traced it and then fill it in I
mean up right dude this is really
impressed that went that one is there
it's a video game icon
I got pit deck deck out of one of these
brand deals dude this is real I thought
this was gonna be bad I though there's
me awkward moment of the podcast this is
gonna be on commenting it's not good but
it's better than you and expect
from Stevo here's the thing I can't tell
if it's good all right
this is legitimately good it is a dick
coming out of a banana but even then
it's very well it's a woman shakiest
lion said to that and think dicks are
shaky I mean it's it's I always see
Diggs drunk so this is looks like to me
exactly on three hard kombucha I was so
can I not get tattoos is it not
attractive for a woman to have her dog
has exceptionally fucking attractive
forum tattooed Lex's standards for our
really but she's just like has excellent
taste she does she just has really a
case maybe she can help me because I
want to get yeah their names because the
tattoos I have are white because I kind
of chickened out so I got them all in my
about that yeah so there you go it's
more like scarification really and it
hurts
I learned twice as much as a regular
fucking tattoo but so I have I love you
and white on my forearm and then I have
a anchor here and then I got this when I
never will never take his antics again
my first and only time taking a xanax
it's funny I my back tattoo of this
heart
there's my fallback portrait of me that
was one of my ideas for the first
Jackass movie and it right there was
like 16 hours all told yeah 16 plus and
cross for four visits to this legendary
artist wasn't Jack Rudy mm-hmm and on
one of them it was really three sessions
because one of the visits was a false
alarm
where I thought that taking xanax would
help with the Pink's this was the most
fucking painful you would think like
rather crazy Jack I should have done
that hurts like what was the most
painful stunt your side
every venture to say that my fucking
back tattoo was the most painful shit
I've because it's like a tedious
nettlesome pain of the in the back is
just a nerves
yeah the back tattoo it and went on
forever and I was the biggest bitch that
this guy ever fucking had in his chair
he was just like I thought you were
supposed to be some kind of fucking
tough guy you were the most like
annoying this maddening fucking bitch
that I could hear him here I'm thinking
it hear the voice oh my god I could
fucking hear and and and then so it
hurts about I would go in for the next
session thinking like oh my god I'm so
dreading this like what can I do to make
it hurt less and I took a bunch of xanax
to thinking it would help with the pain
yeah but then I was just fuckin falling
out of the chair and he said dude get
the fuck out his shit so get the fuck
out of here I can't tattoo a guy who's
slumping in the fall I got laughs that
body fucking asshole think that guy just
disliked me so much and it was the worst
I mean it everyone wants it cuz I did a
thing where I was like what do you want
to ask me now steve-o in the show today
and so much was like uh stuff he's
already answered so many times but I am
so curious about your relationship with
pain and fear cuz I heard you talk about
fear earlier and it kind of surprised me
like when you were just I was fearful
about something and I just was like okay
I just picture you as being someone
who's so fearless like what what's on
your list of fears I mean the pain
doesn't really seem like one of them
physical pain I I'm not like any like
particular like pain you know I don't
have anything like threshold any hice
threshold for pain I just have like such
a an absurd like hunger for attention
it's just that like that's what drives
me like it's not that I don't feel pain
and for that matter if I didn't feel
pain or if any of my buddies the the we
did jackass like if in the absence of
pain there would be no reaction which is
what makes the footage compelling you
know
in the absence of fear you have that you
know it would just be boring to watch
and it's the fact that we're not we're
not like fearless or weird like you know
immune to pain like we're actually like
we really have that that trepidation we
really have that that fear that reaction
you know I think that that's what makes
it compelling we're not like
particularly tough guys we're just like
such fucking attention whores so we'll
do it you know that and make it feel
like what drives this is a little bit
different for each of the guys but yeah
I'm not I feel pain very much as much as
anybody else and I guess like I guess
hide certain kinds of pain I can
tolerate
better than than the average person and
some I don't know but I just wanted them
willing to do it and I'm not like an
adrenaline junkie or a thrill seeker
really
the temper just an attention whore you
know cuz I'd only enjoy like I I'm
terrified of roller coasters oh why do
it
gross fucking hate it but also there's a
bunch of other people on when there's no
camera
there's a camera GoPro on that jump that
biggest fear ever bungee jumping like I
did have you jumped out of a plane for
my for my new hour
no no for my new hour I did all these
new stunts oh no and I made a little
called the bucket list tour and and so
like that it was like this bottom of the
barrel stunts and I was like the first
like that the first joke of my hour is
yeah guys I'm in a fucked up situation
I'm steve-o in my forty's it's bad it's
fucking awful you know like you know I
feel like I got a you know I gotta hurry
up before it gets creepy to watch me do
these things I'm shaking some hands on
purpose soon I'll just be shitting I'm
going all out you know I'm just knock
out like the unfinished business of it
where there's very few ideas that I had
the word like sitting around that never
happened and for very good reasons but
one
them was and secretly it was because I
was afraid of skydiving I don't wanna
fuck with it
so whenever anybody asked me have I ever
been skydiving my might and my go-to
answer was not fuck that everybody does
that that's not a stunt oh it's basic
its basic I said says it's just too
basic for me when it wouldn't the
reality was that I just don't fucking
want to do I don't want any fucking
partner so I built in I built into the
Ted to my resistance to the skydiving I
said it's basic I said if I ever go
skydiving because the first time you do
it you have to have a guy strapped onto
your back that's a tandem guy I said if
I ever go skydiving I'm gonna be butt
fucking naked with a dude on my back
furiously jacking off and I'm gonna
fucking time it with the dude on my back
jacking off such that like I'm a
simultaneously falling out of an
airplane while I'm coming everywhere I
described that he had some on his wrist
the camera seemed to indicate that it
went into the one Mountain on the side
of the plane and what were you thinking
about I brought it I brought a DVD
player with me this was my exception
okay then to the note put the porn yeah
yeah last was my this was my what I love
the idea that you've been off porn for
so long that you went to like jenna
jameson like you haven't it was dude it
was it was fucked up I ended up like not
even realizing I put like that the title
of the the DVD I chose was like anal
destroyers - we haven't seen a no
destroyers what I mean it like it just
it was
it's a crazy thing and then the level is
the layers of this means just like and
and the hour that I do is it's the story
of these just absurd ideas that work for
so many years too much to actually go
through with yeah so it's kind of like
wow what was too much it's something
interesting and and like there's nary
anything on the list of stunts that I
did for this new hour that that one way
or another didn't have implications yeah
on my relationship with Lex I'd Lex had
a real tough time with I'm going
skyjacking not do it by but there was a
tough one you know and I was really
sensitive like well I remember the first
time I saw you performing some of this
you were on stage just killing telling
us story about when you proposed to her
you shit on a fan and right like hit her
in the face and I just made me like this
girl is fucking I described that as that
time I knew she was the one I found once
and for all the shit hit the fan
i I got I got like a little crew of
people and and like this the first
little fuckin droplet of shits man goes
flying except relax just Josh fucking
holds her ground the bail smiler face he
like honestly I don't care what you
think is funny but if you're in
relationships you guys have to think the
same shit is funny dude I also use like
out of everything that I've said in this
podcast which looks like it's just
categorically not a fan of I will tell
you the but I'm about to say the one
thing that will mortify her above don't
ruin my friendship with her friendship
without you I mean I would say mortify
her I really say this I'm beaming with
pride
I've been together for for over three
years
you asked how long were we together
before we before I proposed it was
January 20th that I proposed to her our
first kiss was February 5th it was just
every year together yeah and only in the
last month two months she freely toots
audibly was it an accident the first
time I don't know you'd have to ask can
we get her in here yes do we get her in
Hannah no we can't okay that's gonna be
a bushing her that's gonna be a fight in
the car no no I don't think so
you're already let's not okay do you
think we can ask her if she wants to
meet if she wants it cut out say hey I
feel like if flux wanted to be up here
she'd be up there nah she does not have
the same desperate need for attention
you know he's fucking something she's
sitting by the pool fine she's exhausted
shit did she text no I mean I have to
let you go at some point but I had like
a couple more questions for you okay
about her so right I really wanted to be
here that's the sweetest thing and my
question for you I asked this to all the
guys on the show that are married
because we're FaceTime here women always
want to know when when was it clear she
you're like I can't I can't oh my god
she is I know she's the most gorgeous
we're talking about you uh we're talking
about you we're talking about how he
shit on you during his proposal how much
trouble am I in
before I wanted my friendship with her
how much trouble am I in for saying that
we've been together for over three years
but I know and I'm beaming with pride
when I say this and I'm so proud that
our relationship has reached the level
that in just last one or two months
like you you you aren't apologetically
proudly and audibly toots when she does
it like it
I melt I'm not because like that's
intimacy you're vegan so this is very
there are some definitely right we got
oh my god babe I love you so much but I
just want to know is was it the first
one in accident you know I don't even
remember but her farts are so cute
that's when it's love I think a lot of
people are always like trying to figure
out like what do I show in front of my
man what do I not show in for a man the
thing is that if it's the right person
it's gonna be cute instead of gross it's
like you should be able to do that one
right I mean they're I think they're
what I love about it so much is that
that the idea of the woman who I love
like uncomfortably suppressing like the
urge to fart you know like like having
like you know that pain in her stomach
or like or anything like like for her to
be like hey you know what it's like I
want her to know like babe I got you a
guy you fucking let it rip yeah perky
little butthole and I feel like her
farts are just little unicorn beeps oh
my god she's so beautiful it's just like
a my girl my girl is so beautiful being
slaughtered yeah I want everyone on the
youtube version and then also I really
she really captured my heart when you
guys did this YouTube video that was a
prank
where her tampon was falling out like
around people and look I've done prank
shows I did we ambushed you with that so
badly I was like Magnus I was like I was
like this footage on its own is like
it's it's not like they're like it needs
another like another level another
dimension to really like make this video
account and I was like just getting like
turning it into a reaction video would
give it another layer and I was like
who'd we get and I was just like man a
woman who can like kind of bring to the
male audience like some perspective like
something you know to be like yeah I see
a woman reacted I think for the male
viewers would help I just caught up hey
wait can you come I didn't tell you what
it was can you come over I want to ask
you a question a camera and just I
ambushed you with it and it was kind of
fucked up to do that no I think that's
posed oh that's real friends and I could
have said no I'm even you are so
hilarious in that and in that video that
video performed really poorly I've come
to realize because use tampons are a
little much like they're just you use
tampons guys guys are cool with a lot of
shit but once you start talking like a
brandishing like like what's the word
I'm like pointing yeah once you start
dropping bloody tampons me I just I have
seen some ballsy shit in my day that
most of my shot came from Lux doing the
fucking prank and not breaking dude I
was like I wouldn't have been able to do
that like that was I was like this bitch
it's like next-level honey when Whitney
like started crying like her eyes like
you could see him tear up when I told
her that I when I said that I spent all
this time working to be
come the man that the love of my life
deserves isn't that this I can't that's
gonna make me cry again I am yeah I just
like that yeah I described as such I
described it as such and I even said
like out loud that that I I feel like
there's like you know anxious and
awkward to describe having like you know
this this shitty past word where I
aspired to be scumbag you know but like
what when I feel so grateful for and and
so passionate about is that I got to
work to preemptively become the man the
who you deserve you know and and yeah by
the way Lux the viewers are gonna want
you to write a book we're gonna be like
how the fuck has she done that what is
this what is she doing how do we get our
men to behave like this Jesus she runs a
tight ship
oh my god please write a relationship
book I will fuckin read it what are you
are you doing kegels what is it what's
kegels it's when you squeeze your vagina
to make it small you take it's not so
loose you need to tighten it up Lexus is
great I mean the farts I mean the farts
sounding like that means the butthole is
on point okay yeah man dude like I love
Institute's
that is so cute well this is really
throwing a wrench in my whole theory
because I was like I need to be more
feminine in relationships I need to
start farting and peeing and why it
takes so the world work up to three
years it what's the and that's what was
so significant about that breakthrough
is that three years you pee in front of
each other
I've got like out we do double on each
other okay we did double-decker she sits
down and then I sit on top of her and
push my Weiner throw I pee through her
legs
I mean granted we only did that for
camera but you don't hope in front of
each other we have not proved in front
of each other I mean I will my life no
they wouldn't had told me that I needed
to Professor her she just fucking stood
and she even she advanced for them to
get the shots she didn't budge but to
move in for a better shot
that's a warrior
they fucking he's wearing a miniskirt
and she's at one point like checks she
goes oh do I have shit in my vagina
waiting to happen
oh my god what's going on it's a wedding
are we having a wedding we belligerently
stubbornly waiting until we buy our land
for to open up our animal sanctuary love
it love it to do a wedding right we want
to get married on that Lee because I got
a vasectomy because we don't want to
have kids
mm-hmm there's another bucket list you
have your goats and you've got your diet
and I'm glad too that like would take
our time where like where we have we
built a little barn at our house we've
got three goats we've got four dogs two
cats I desperately want five chickens
yeah have them gonna spot those those yo
T's will get them so you gotta have a
lunch it likes is the voice of reason
here she's like look I do so much the
most of the work I'm not prepared to add
to our work life we just get loads up
here yeah get up here cuz I know you
guys I have to let you out at some point
but I just want to ask you one question
about come up here if you want see she
does that she's not a narcissist
I have self-esteem I don't need to take
my shirt off facade cash there's
something so wrong seven o'clock on a
Tuesday I'm chillin I'm not tap dancing
for strangers all right love you cuz I'm
just so curious especially love yo
especially with everything we talked
about like a wedding like for me as an
entertainer was I was really struggling
with it cuz I was like well it's gotta
be funny and it's gotta be this and I
have to have and it was like this weird
thing when I was like I can plan a TV
show I can write an hour of
entertainment but like planning a
wedding like I kept going like I don't
know what people want for me I have to
entertain people am I gonna be funny
like it really fuck with that day you're
so in female you're like you're not like
that that's such a fucking female
thought you know I don't get it like
what so it's it's like the I was I got
to train my dogs to like bring them with
you with women and fucking wedding
dresses like how much thoughts can go
into this this garment that you're gonna
wear once I know but give donors to the
exclusion dition to believe we only
start to matter as a person when we put
that garment on from dolls and Barbies
and American girls we're taught we're
only valuable as people once we earn
that garment right I mean there's a
whole word for that hag has not achieved
that spinster hag
you old cougar all that shit and if you
just have a photo of you in that dress
people are going okay she's worth what
she's a right you know what I mean like
we it's crazy it's like a guy either
getting a tattoo or scar on his face or
getting in his first bar fight or
whatever having a big dick whatever it
is we have been if we don't have that
garment we're not what Louisville
schools
we're not fuckable you know it's really
it's really mean even before I was
engaged anyone and then the the wedding
it's like this it's like an afternoon
it's a fucking
that's the one day they get to have
photos taken of them people bring them
presents like I feel like in their whole
life is about looking forward to that
I'm so excited to marry Lex that like
and I don't give a fuck about the
wedding dress and I don't give a fuck
about the the wedding I just want to be
married to her yeah that's and we're not
any like big rush because like it the
idea of our future being like are the
darling animal sanctuary and to your
point about about like Heather you know
this founder syndrome I'm not sure what
that means but the the idea that there
are just people who go about like with
good intentions just the wrong fucking
way you bring in a bunch of animals they
don't know how to take care of these
animals that's not you though because
you're to self-examine these are
essentially hoarders these are
essentially people that are exploiting
and using animals for their own either
financial gain to get donations that
they're not even giving to the animals
or like I mean there was a guy this
motherfucker was going in a rescue
person with a lot of followers on
Instagram I'm not gonna blow him up
right now cuz I already destroyed his
life but he not his life but I stopped
him from being able to keep getting
animals from shelters he would take dogs
to vets and say please amputate one of
the legs they go well he doesn't need to
and they he asked for it so that he
could post videos of like I saved this
dog now it has three life because he was
fucking blowing up on Instagram because
the three-legged dog videos do very well
I mean this is there are some people on
my pathologically insane founder
syndromes when you get so drunk on the
attention you're getting from being a
hero that you just essentially start
having magical thinking and actually
abusing the very animals that you are
supposed to be saving it's like hoarders
when you when you I think that there's a
lot of just sort of ignorance here where
people aren't even like you know like
that that way you just described sounded
just maliciously fucking wrong sick I
think there are people who are
innocently ignorant yeah yeah and I
don't want to be that you know like I
don't want to be that so and you never
would because the kind of person who
says that never will be that do you know
what I mean like you're already just too
self-aware you
and to like on top of your own shit you
know cuz I can try I do it even I'm
sorry you know I want so badly to rescue
an animal I've had my ear bitten off
I've had dogs get in fights I've had
dogs rip other dog's faces off you know
just because I want so badly to help
that I what you are so obsessed
motherfucker you just told me that I'm
so female can't even focus without
looking at this fucking Gaghan just suck
it dick already you just put it inside
just kick it I guess I'm just sitting
here and going like I'm single now and
I'm enough to dating and I realize I'm
gonna have to keep listen to guys talk
about gadgets I mean is you seem so
happy about that yeah it's just who
fucking care like who fucking rides a
fuck but you're so happy and in love
yeah yeah I mean just this is wild I
mean I just I'm so happy for you
that this is bringing you this kind of
joy because I fucking hate like the iDEN
can never figure out the arm I'm always
telling my producer I feel like I'm
hitting it like you know no it's it was
one thing I feel like at the tip of
Jimmy I can move around with a finger I
feel and then and then I actually get
mad at the mics as I hear myself in the
pod cause I'm like oh god doesn't mic
sir making me sound loud and nasal and
people like no that's just how you sound
yeah well like on Ron Brogan he's got
the the mic arm coming in from above
which is like kind of like I mean he
works his way around it's fine yeah
evidently he's doing okay do that right
but but but this is so great because it
comes in from underneath yeah it's like
super cheaper than than the one Rogan
uses I feel like my producer paid you to
say this because for last two months
I've been like I don't like that the arm
it comes in from underneath and if you
want it to come in from above it will
and and I'm just I just think it's
fucking fan time can't wait to have this
is make this is really making me lose a
lot of leverage with my producer because
this isn't like an ongoing thing where
he's like trust me this is bad
I'm like I don't if you're I've heerd
started a podcast if you have a podcast
everyone is sitting up for your podcast
guy and these these ones with like that
where it's like you can see the spring
on it and it's like there's just a
fucking nasty
I just to me the most garbage that you
can do is just be holding like two
people sitting down holding microphones
you're sick yeah wondering like I've
satisfied my like I've covered the the
FedEx I mean I can't wait I can't wait
you have I walk in here and dude the guy
like I've got him on speed dial the the
the vice-president of sales and
marketing yeah for these mic arms and
the first thing I did was take pictures
and text them to my homeboy how much
longer do I have to hear what I'm done
no I'm glad that I'm watching this
because I've been off I've been on the
bench for a while dating and I know a
lot of being in a relationship is
happiness you were recently engaged yeah
I was engaged and and what happened
there I mean I just I still don't know
how to articulate it let's talk about
the my guard this is just so bad II know
it's just it's just I still don't have a
way to articulate it and I'm part of my
recoveries being able to say I don't
know
hey all good you know who knows maybe
you didn't have the right person maybe I
just need to live on your farm but then
we'll just tattoo each other all day and
as well as this until I'm able to get a
what you're gonna get like a full front
because if you have horses someone has
to be around all the time and they can
colic like I mean they're just very
delicate and you know are they're
ambitious yeah in the in the world of
and it's a wild amount of shit
I mean it's expensive and I want to do
that I want to do donkeys I'm gonna do
horses I'm gonna do the whole thing but
I probably need a couple years to get
that get that land right get that Lance
I love how unapologetically just animal
loving your
is it crazy well do people think I'm
crazy I don't think so I think that it's
I think because it the way you do it is
not preachy I could name some people
yeah who are just really tough to follow
not because it's like just stop you know
not like the whole like militant vegan
thing I think is is a little bit it to
me it makes the people that you actually
could convince or I think you could
interest shuts them down and makes them
not it's not I shut down when people
yell at me and play it's it's there's
there's a real feeling that if you're
not vegan enough you know that like
where we start like actually alienating
people who are on the same fucking team
that's exactly it so I I look and I
don't post most of my animal rescue
stuff because a lot of the reason I'm
able to get animals out of abusive
situations is the agreement I say is I
won't put this on social media your name
will not be involved give me the tiger
and give me the horse nothing else will
be said right so that's a big part of it
so most of it is anonymous so but I do
try to post if I'm trying to get a dog a
home or trying to just go hey we're in
quarantine great time to foster a dog
you know like never want to bully people
but because I have so many animal people
sort of in my world which I'm grateful
for but I'll get messages where if I'm
wearing a shirt people go you're wearing
a silk shirt and that's worm rape and
I'm just like okay right you look like
I'm proud of myself for not even having
noticed that you have animals on your
shirt because like I've just not not
once have I looked at your breasts you
have blinders on in a way that I'm not
even a woman to you
he has not even looked below my neck I
mean granted this is probably just the
least sexual managed to neuter myself
with this shirt but I just mean I'll be
wearing something or or if someone sees
me eating honey they'll be like that's
be rape by I post videos like taking
bees out of the pool like I'm I got in
so much trouble okay it was it was when
I was in that same fucking theatre in
Vancouver
that someone I came through the line and
they said hey you know something like
like are you still vegan hurt and I was
like oh you know like one second when I
got cats and then I was just like I was
like fuck it you know and I just you
know that became pescetarian feel like
you know like I gotta feed my cats well
yeah I gotta feed my cats me like I said
like my dogs like I just don't don't
fuckin dig vegan dog food I decide part
of the reason I don't eat red meat is I
feed so much red meat to my dogs and so
I try to just go like okay this is like
that yeah and also like go as far as
fish yeah and I also like sorry chicken
everybody I'd like we've been doing some
chicken like but also we tour a lot so
there's times or it's like and because I
had such crazy eating disorder stuff
like if I'm in an airport and I the only
choice is like chicken soup or like Diet
Coke like I got a I got a do that or
else I'm in the slippery slope of my
which Diet Coke like just like if I'm in
its
you know the Tulsa Airport and there's
only a Sbarro pizza and a Hudson news
right like I can't just only drink a
doctor for lunch because I'm like not
eating chicken like that gets into a
whole other unhealthy right sort of
thing but uh but yet I also it I also
think people just need to be on their
own right and part of it too
everything outside I said told this this
girl that like you know I've a just the
line got blurred like I eat fish I
actually subscribe to the belief that
fish is good for me yeah you know
there's certainly better than all the
fucking like fake mock meat bullshit
yeah really not good for me yeah and you
know so like eggs and fish and then it
was like and then I didn't think
anything of it yeah you know and I think
that she came back through the line
again just talk to me again to say how
she disproves fish Fisher you know
Cynthia or whatever it was yeah and then
the next day I got in the airplane and
now I'm seeing things like on like the
Instagram whatever it was like oh he's
not fucking vegan anymore it's like he's
fucking
trader he's a hypocrite he's and I was
just like wait what and then in the end
I was like it's foolishly responded oh
yeah there was are there was like some
direct message or says I'd forget but
then now there's like it's in a Facebook
forum my god you know and it was just
like and I just got so at my wit's end
I'd finally was just like you know I
just want a picture an old picture of me
and it's crammed into a fridge with all
these fruits and veggies on you know and
I was just like man then my captioner
just like fuck you know vegans can be
really annoying man you know like really
annoying I just wanted to say like like
what when people are like on your team
you know let's not alienate people who
are really like proactive about like
furthering progress for animal welfare
yeah you know when somebody isn't quite
up to your personal standard of vegan
Asst when when they're not like let's
not attack the people who are really
proactive and benefiting you know what
I'll say I think at anything extremism
is where it should hits the fan so I'm
sure there are cool Republicans there's
cool Democrats it's just the extreme
cool Republican look I know some fucking
cool Republicans who are like you know
very liberal in some areas and very and
I know some that go back and forth the I
can't imagine being one you know but I
just think to me it's always like and I
sometimes do come to the defense of the
non-vocal vegans or just again do what
you want man I'm gonna do it like Ian
Edwards and Neal Brennan right like you
Travis Barker Yeah right I've known them
for 10 years we've had you know Greg
Neil and I you have dinner used up
dinner once a week never once did I even
talk about you know right so it's like
there are some cool ones we just of
course hear from right didactic right
right right nasty ones yeah and and yeah
and you're absolutely right there are
totally wonderful vegan people and
it is just layer just let's do the best
you can extreme yeah yeah do the bribe
you can you know I just I had a pig and
I stumbled upon getting a pig I didn't
plan on getting a pig once you fucking
have a pig and you see how smart they
are it's just like I just couldn't go
back you know what I mean it was just
one of those things with just pigs that
was just like oh yeah dude like I just
that means so much smarter than my dogs
this is right you know you know it was
for me was when I was hearing all the
voices on drugs yeah like I was I was
just I needed to know more about what I
had this connection with like I was like
the the barriers were a road and now I'm
interacting with these spirit entities
and so I was I was you know I took to
the internet to research spirituality
and like what's gonna learn what what's
going on what am i privy to yeah let me
learn about what it is and I came upon
this video of like a fucking Krishna
consciousness guru in India and he just
said one thing the company said how can
you expect to be saved if you eat meat
like she seemed like you know and I
think by anybody's standards whether
it's like go to heaven be saved Nirvana
like whatever it is like there's some
kind of a consensus that the human
experience is is essentially we're in a
fucking Jam and we're trying to get out
we want to ascend as we're in this
fucking thing and it's like we need to
be saved we need to fucking get out of
here we need to go to heaven but
whatever we're in we're in we're in a
fucking Jam and like the idea of this is
to somehow like no matter what religion
or spiritual like you know wisdom is
like our purpose is to get out of this
Jam by finding salvation yeah and this
guy who is like this spiritual how can
you expect to be saved and then I
thought oh no I'm not going to be saved
because I'm fucking me and I immediately
I stopped eating meat except for fish at
that time yeah because I was like all
with fucking Jesus like was a fisherman
man like has to be cool so long then I
have to let you go good so long that's
let you go but I love you and the
like long overdue but I'm glad we did it
when your podcast was out oh shit I
never knew we talked about hydro we
talked about a little bit dude the
doctor did your episode I just listened
it was fucking great the Ronda Rousey
episode I watched the entire thing in
one sitting
it was just so fun - what like you get
people that are so like you have such
good chemistry with but you're in like
different worlds as you know I love
having all the our friends on the
comedian's we all get to see but it's
just been really refreshing like how
you're curating your guests it's it's
just such a i'm just tormenting myself
but i gotta get someone that like but
never guess i'm gonna have like I got a
comedian I gotta get a musician an
athlete yeah you're like you being a
perfectionist about it that's good
that's what makes podcasts great that's
something I don't think you should maybe
fix about yourself okay wanting to be
excellent that's fuckin awesome yeah I
you know I want to be fuckin no I that's
why you're gonna fuckin be the king of
this state alright that's it I give you
a hug but don't get up fuck away Fred
alright love you I always had this very
awkwardly everyone knows that bye guys
love you don't ride elephants thank you
see you on the gram and on the twitch
and on the tick-tock dude I fell off
[Music]